[Music]
foreign
guys how you doing Ed Sheeran surprises
some lucky young musicians you can say
it made their day
it's nice to have surprises in life it's
nice to have surprises the Grammy winner
made an unexpected stop at a Florida
high school crashing band practice while
they were rehearsing one of his hits I'm
at Middleton High School and they've
been learning my song eyes closed with
the band
[Music]
I'm gonna go and surprise them
that's amazing guys how you doing what's
going on thanks for doing that but the
surprises didn't end there see I've also
brought some guitars to give to you guys
for the music department and uh
and also I'm playing a sold out Stadium
tomorrow but I've got tickets for all of
you guys to come so
and the best thing is I make a living
making people happy which is
Wicked thing you know like I get paid to
make it on this month that's the best
job you can have but they didn't have to
wait for the concert to see Ed sing live
[Music]
real special moment and um I said that's
that's the moment that you look for not
not everything else it's like the real
real mothers Ed Sheeran showed up during
practice it's one of the most amazing
experiences I think we've ever had at
Middleton here and Sharon was singing
with me and I was like
all my friends are mad at me
[Music]
yeah we bet times Forever Frozen for
these talented kids who scored the
experience of a lifetime I hope so I
hope so it's sweet surprise comes just
weeks after he won the copyright trial
over his song Thinking Out Loud
[Music]
an eyewitness in the courtroom told E.T
at the time Ed seemed very pleased with
the verdict and gave everyone on his
legal team a big hug and since that
Victory adds back to doing what he loves
most performing impromptu Street shows
[Music]
and improper venues
[Applause]
[Music]